donc j'ai vu le titre de cette session
to work in your eyes sonne donc j'ai
décidé
j'ai essayé d'être original et je vais
vous parler des horizons et le mot
horizons pour un physicien pour un
astrophysicien pour un cosmologues
puisque c'est ce que je suis ça résonne
d'une manière particulière parce que
c'est un concept que nous utilisons sans
arrêt et cette notion d'horizon nous
avons une définition des horizons que je
vais pas vous donner en détail mais dont
je vous donnerai une intuition qui est
assez curieuse parce que l'horizon n'est
pas quelque chose de matériel c'est
quelque chose que nous définissons d'une
manière assez abstraite et auquel
pourtant on attribue des propriétés on
peut attribuer une température une
entropie de l'information quelque chose
comme ça alors le départ la notion d'
horizons bien sûr c'est quand vous êtes
en mer
quand vous êtes sur un bateau vous
regardez autour de vous et puis il ya
une certaine distance quelques
kilomètres au delà de laquelle vous ne
pouvez pas à percevoir ce qui est sur la
mer comme vous d'autres bateaux qui
naviguent s'ils sont à plus de 10 km par
exemple vous ne les voyez pas donc
autour de vous il ya une limite fictive
un rond comme sur montrouge que vous
appelez l'horizon bien sûr cette ligne
n'existe pas sur la surface de la mer
mais pour vous elle représente la limite
de ce que vous êtes capable de voir ce
qui est au delà de l'horizon
vous ne voyez pas et petite propriété
assez spectaculaire c'est que si vous
montez si le marin par exemple s'élève
en grimpant sur le mât de sur son mât et
bien l'horizon va s'éloigner
et pourtant c'est le même personnage son
horizon s'éloigne lorsqu'il monte sur le
mât tout simplement
d'où vient tout ce ci que les rayons
lumineux et sombre page en ligne droite
et que la terre est courbe donc avec
simplement cette connaissance là on
arrive à très bien expliquer l'existence
de l'horizon et à calculer
son rayon par exemple donc ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'horizon
d'abord il est différent pour chacun de
nous le marin qui est ici on aura en
horizon centré autour de lui celui qui
est de la aura un horizon centré autour
de lui donc l'horizon diffère pour
chacun et puis il peut varier même avec
l'altitude
bon ça c'est pas les horizons dont nous
parlons en cosmologie en relativité en
physique fondamentale parce que là je
viens de vous parler d'horizon qui sont
dans l'espace
mais quand on fait de la physique
fondamentale on raisonne on raisonne
dans l'espace temps c'est-à-dire avec
l'espace et avec le temps et on va
définir des notions d'horizon qui prenne
en compte la dimension temporelle pour
m'expliquer je vais essayer d'introduire
cette notion d'une manière très simple
qui nous concerne nous personnellement
et vous parler en termes d'événements
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un événement vous
savez tous que c'est c'est quelque chose
qui arrive à un certain endroit un
certain instant quand je suis en train
de prononcer cette parole c'est un
événement s'il ya une mouche qui se pose
sur la table à tel endroit c'est un
événement que vous avez deux particules
qui se rencontrent par exemple dans un
accélérateur de particules
c'est un événement parce que ça se
produit à un endroit bien défini à un
moment bien défini si vous avez une
étoile qui explose quelque part dans
l'univers le moment de son explosion
c'est un événement une comète qui
rentrent en collision avec jupiter c'est
un événement donc voilà un événement
c'est quelque chose qui est localisée
dans le temps et dans l'espace
et ce qui est intéressant c'est que moi
même
en ce moment je vais pouvoir définir ce
que c'est que mon horizon
je vais m'intéresser à tous les
évènements qui peuvent se produire dans
l'univers et essayer de distinguer parmi
ces événements ce qu'ils peuvent avoir
ou qui ont eu une influence sur mon état
actuel
par exemple si j'ai rencontré quelqu'un
il y à quelques temps évidemment ça fait
partie de mon horizon parce que ça a une
influence sur moi
si à un moment donné
il ya eu un courant d'air qui m'a
apporté un virus et bien évidemment
c'est un événement qui fait partie de
mon horizon puisque ça m'a rendu malade
et si je suis malade aujourd'hui c'est
parce que j'ai rencontré ce virus si si
j'ai regardé il y as je sais plus
combien d'années maintenant leur
transmission deux premiers hommes
mettant le pied sur la lune
c'est un événement qui m'a influencé par
ce que j'ai regardé cette émission
peut-être c'est ça qui m'a donné ma
vocation pour faire de l'astrophysique
et donc c'est quelque chose qui a
influencé ma vie si je suis comme je
suis c'est parce que j'ai vu cette
émission de télé à cette époque
si je l'avais pas vu je serai autrement
donc ça a influencé mon état actuel mon
état actuel dépend sans doute de tous
les événements qui ont pu m'influencer
donc parmi tous les événements qu'ils
ont qui ont eu lieu dans l'univers je
vais distinguer ceux qui ont pu avoir
une influence sur moi et les autres et
je vais appeler la différence entre les
deux l'horizon il ya une certaine limite
qui va délimiter les deux c'est ça qui
est l horizon donc mon passé finalement
ce qui me concerne c'est ce qui est à
l'intérieur de l'horizon très bien bon
maintenant ce dont il faut s'apercevoir
c'est que cette notion d' horizons elle
va changer avec le temps
c'est à dire que supposons par exemple
qu'en ce moment il est une comète qui
rencontre la planète mars
bon je ne peux pas le savoir tout de
suite ce que la planète mars s'il y a de
la lumière de l'information qui m'arrive
ça mais huit minutes
donc ça ne fait pas partie de mon
horizon pourtant dans huit minutes
je pourrais voir ce qui se passe la
lumière le l'afutt auge de cet événement
m'arrivera dans huit minutes le temps de
propagation la lumière depuis la planète
mars jusqu'à moi donc dans huit minutes
cet événement-là fera partie de mon
horizon ce qui veut dire que mon horizon
lorsque le temps s'écoule contient de
plus en plus des veines
mon horizon grandi mon horizon en feu
c'est à dire que le simple écoulement du
temps que je ne peux pas modifiées que
je ne peux pas contrôler fait que mon
horizon grandi un peu de la même manière
que le marin qui monte sur le mât et qui
voit son horizon évolué alors ce qui est
important c'est que pour qu'un événement
fasse partie de mon horizon
eh bien il faut que j'en ai connaissance
il faut en tout cas qu'il m'ait
influencé il faut qu'il y ait quelque
chose qui était transmis de cet
événement jusqu'à moi par exemple
simplement de l'information
quand le cosmonaute a mis le pied sur la
lune il a été filmé le film a été
retransmis par télétransmission jusqu'à
la terre ensuite par le canal de la
télévision moi j'ai regardé l'écran de
la télévision
et voilà toute la chaîne qui a transmis
cette information de manière à ce que ça
m'influence
si par exemple il y a le tirage de la
loterie nationale et que sort le numéro
qui correspond au billet que j'ai acheté
ça n'est pas encore dans mon horizon
ça va rentrer dans mon horizon au moment
où j'en aurai connaissance c'est à dire
plus tard parce que l'information ne
sera arrivé par un certain canal d'abord
sarr a été proclamée par l'aplomb salle
jury ensuite ça aura été
retransmis par la radio et je l'aurai
finalement un prix donc il ya cette
notion d' horizons qui est dans ce cas
là subjective et que et qui dépend de la
personne évidemment qui parle et qui
évolue également avec le temps bon ça
nous amène à la notion de raison qu'on
étudie en physique qui est très lié à
ceux ci c'est à dire que quand vous avez
un événement
je répète l'événement ça peut être je
suis ici je parle mais n'importe quoi
qui est localisée dans l'espace et dans
le temps c'est un événement à chaque
événement on associe un horizon qui l
ensemble de tous les événements qui ont
pu l'influencer
c'est à dire tel qu' il y a quelque
chose qui a fait le lien entre cet
événement et l'autre de la manière que
je vous ai présenté pour ce qui me
concerne
sauf que mon physique évidemment c'est
un petit peu plus formalisé
parce que ces événements c'est la
transmission d'un signal
par exemple de la lumière des photons ou
n'importe quel rayonnement
électromagnétique mais ça peut être
aussi une onde gravitationnelle puisque
vous savez que récemment on a enregistré
des événements qui se sont produits il
ya des milliards d'années qui sont
simplement la collision de deux trous
noirs simplement et que ça ait mis des
ondes gravitationnelles qui nous sont
arrivées aujourd'hui qu'on a détecté
donc peu importe finalement le canal que
prend l'information pour ne pas revenir
elle est toujours supporté par un
certain signal est ce que nous savons
c'est que n'importe quel signal ne peut
jamais se propager plus vite que la
lumière
ça c'est une des grandes lois de la
physique et finalement c'est cette loi
qui va permettre de donner une
consistance à la notion d' horizons
je m'explique je m'explique en
introduisant ce qu'on appelle l'horizon
cosmologique
vous savez qu'aujourd'hui nos nous
décrivons l'univers par des modèles
cosmologiques qu'on appelle des modèles
de big bang
pour résumer ces modèles nous disent que
l'univers existe du moins il existe à
peu près tel qu'il est maintenant depuis
13 milliards d'années 13 7 milliards
d'années
bon très bien ça veut dire quoi ça une
application immédiate
ça veut dire que quels que soient les
événement que l'on observe la lumière
l'information qui vient de cet événement
jusqu'à nous n'a pas pu mettre plus que
13 milliards d'années mais si
l'information n'a pas eu plus que 13
milliards d'années pour nous parvenir
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut voir un objet
que s'il est à une distance inférieure à
13 milliards d'années-lumière 13,7
autrement dit il existe une limite
fictives dans l'univers une espèce de
grande sphère fictive encore une fois
qui nous entourent qui a un rayon de
13,7 milliards d'années lumière
c'est beaucoup évidemment qui représente
l'ensemble des objets que nous sommes
capables d'observer quand je dis objet
c'est les étoiles les galaxies les
coizard les amas de galaxies
tout ce qu'on peut imaginer tout ce que
nous observons par l'intermédiaire des
télescopes des détecteurs particules des
détecteurs d'ondés gravitationnelles
tout ce que vous voulez c'est à
l'intérieur de cette sphère
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle aussi ça
quelquefois notre univers observable
donc notre univers observable
il est ils forment une grande sphère
d'événements qui est qui a pour surface
exactement notre horizon
mais ce qu'il ya au-delà de l'horizon ça
existe aussi il ya des galaxies au delà
de l'horizon il ya déjà des galaxies qui
sont plus ou moins semblable au nôtre et
on a toutes raisons de penser que c'est
pas parce qu'on ne voit pas ces galaxies
qui sont à l'extérieur de l'horizon
qu'elles sont pas semblables que ce qui
se passe au delà de l'horizon n'est pas
analogue à ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
sauf qu'il ya quelques physiciens qui
veulent finalement avoir des idées un
peu original qui non non non l'autre
côté de l'horizon c'est très différent
on va appeler ça les autres univers ça
se passe pas du tout comme ici bon de
toute manière on n'aura aucun moyen de
le savoir puisque c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas observer
donc si on veut faire de la physique
même de l'astrophysique de la cosmologie
d'une manière assez sûr c'est à dire
d'une manière qu'on puisse vérifier et
bien on ne peut parler que de ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur de notre univers
observable
et si on vous parle d'autres univers un
jour c'est plus de la physique c'est
plus de l'astrophysique cessé de la
fantaisiste
la science fiction alors cet horizon on
l'appelle horizon cosmologique puisque
comme je viens de vous l'expliquer il
est dû au fait que l'univers n'existe
tel qu'il est que depuis 13 milliards
d'années il ya une autre sorte d'horizon
qui est très intéressante qui est
l'horizon m'a associé à un trou noir je
vais pas vous expliquer en détail ce que
c'est qu'un trou noir
mais disons c'est un objet extrêmement
condensé qui exerce une attraction
gravitationnelle très intense et qui
donc est entourée d'une espèce de
membranes fictive sphérique autour de
7,2 ce trou noir qui est telle que tout
événement qui se produit à l'intérieur
de cette membrane nous ne pouvons pas en
avoir connaissance
tout simplement parce que aucun
rayonnement aucun signal ne peut
franchir cette membrane de l'intérieur
vers l'extérieur
donc tout ce qui arrive à l'intérieur de
cette membrane c'est que comme si ça
c'était extérieur à l'univers on ne peut
pas le connaître
et pourtant ça fait partie de l'univers
quand même parce que inversement si vous
êtes à l'intérieur de cette membrane ce
que je ne vous souhaite pas parce que
selon la votre espérance de vie ne sera
pas très longue mais le temps que vous
soyez à l'intérieur de cette membrane
vous pouvez parfaitement voir ce qui
arrive à l'extérieur c'est à dire que
c'est une membrane qui empêche toute
information de sortir mais qui n'empêche
pas du tout l'information de rentrer sur
le trou noir
non seulement l'information mais aussi
la matière qui peut tomber sur le trou
noir parce qu'elle est attirée très
fortement et qui peut faire grossir le
trou noir
bon il ya aussi d'autres sortes d'
horizons dont parle la physique et
l'astrophysique
mais je veux pas faire une liste
complète c'est simplement pour insister
sur le fait premièrement que cette
notion d' horizons
elle est bien défini en physique là je
vous ai donné des intuitions
mais on nous avons des définitions
extrêmement rigoureuse et extrêmement
précise qu'elle ressemble un peu à la
notion intuitive que nous en avons mais
quand même pas tout à fait et que donc
des horizons il y en a de différentes
sortes et il y en a un peu partout et
pour terminer je voudrais juste
mentionner le fait que là je vous ai
passé dont je voulais parler d'horizon
du passé d'ailleurs on se demande si un
événement du passé a pu
mme influencé par exemple mais il ya
aussi les notions symétrique dans
l'horizon dans le futur c'est à dire au
lieu de me demander quels sont les
événements qui ont pu m'influencer je
peux me demander quels sont les
événements dans le futur que moi je peux
influencer
peut-être que c'est plus intéressant et
peut-être que c'est quelque chose qui
nous concerne plus dans cette réunion
parce que tout ce dont on parle
mon avenir bien entendu l'avenir de mes
proches l'avenir de la planète
et bien c'est quelque chose qui est une
somme d'événements
quels sont les événements que je peux
avoir une chance d'influencer c'est à
dire si je veux agir si je veux avoir
une influence sur ce qui se passe autour
de moi il faut que j'essaye d'identifier
quels sont les événements sur lesquels
je peux agir
quelles sont mes moyens moyen peut-être
de toutes sortes en agissant de manière
concrète mais aussi en propageant de
l'information en faisant de la
communication donc un des grands
problèmes que je joue sur lesquels je
vous invite à réfléchir
après avoir beaucoup réfléchi sur les
horizons du passé c'est quelle est votre
raison du futur et sur quoi puis-je
intervenir et comment puis-je intervenir
merci
[Applaudissements]